hey what's up guys it's 6:59 monday may
May 27th I should know what day it is
it's a Memorial Day that was a sound
meaning the Turman starts in less than a
minute people are in the chat James
Clark 84 is first John Dugan saying
first but actually second tee calling
what's up T Kong I have my my kombucha I
went to Whole Foods and got the same
type of kombucha I drank last arena
Kings that propelled me to first place
so I'm gonna try and defend my defend my
honor today more people biscuit fiend
John Davis
now the GM John Davis wait is this not
on the schedule this should be on the
schedule
I'm there's enough to calm /schedule we
have 15 seconds oh maybe maybe because
it just started that I don't know yeah
actually maybe this was overlooked
apologize for that okay
game is starting Nicola Stoughton thanks
for subbing this is king of the hill
meaning I have to get the King to the
center before my opponent does or I have
to go for mates one of those I'm gonna
try and play quickly not sure if I've
heard of this guy before Turin tech I'm
playing a Stafford gambit I played this
line in real chess just not in king of
the hill I mean my King has three
squares away from achieving Nirvana King
D - he's gonna play King C 3 maybe aw
let's develop normally and probably
Castle queenside try and punish this
some nice dubious chess move
maybe this move
those might see four ideas might see
four retreat hmm like Queen h5 doesn't
quite work okay let's play this not
super happy with the opening at Bishop
e2 I have Mike c4 okay now we have a
queenless middle game so my King is
actually safe maybe traveling up the
board I'm gonna try and clear the way
just get to d6 how I get there there
there mm that's very close
help but the king on c7 first I'm
actually very close to winning d5 would
be a crucial mistake yeah now I'm one
square away from winning yes okay I
don't think my opponent realized it was
king of the hill that was funny
now I'm playing Hans Nieman puzzle rush
phenom the king of the hill phenom yes
we'll find out
ah counseling's risky I could take play
rook t1 okay I'm gonna be brave
I might get severely punished
why can I take on d5 takes takes rook t8
let's try it I Kings close to the center
again which is kind of what I want he's
gonna have Bishop e6 I'm queen c5
doesn't work am I already in big trouble
I've Queen d5 to go for that yeah my
king has closed access if I can trade
Queens I'm like almost winning
hey I'm first place nice but okay it's
still very early okay I think I can take
and play a three or I can take and run
with the king it takes you just gonna
have f5
that's very very close I'm gonna go for
it
5i Bishop c4 stuff yeah there's this
whole balance between like real chess
and king of the hill chess so he knows
what's up for those of you who don't
know what's going on you have to get to
the king you have to get the King to the
center of the board to win or you have
to check me normally to win or you have
to flag your opponent to win so sure
we'll see a lot of different ways of
winning let's try this move and maybe c3
it's a solid move Wow
take sticks I'll attack the rook oh the
rook can't move here or here because I
win I fork hmm let's take that
how do I do this let's play this move
for this very tricky position
I can get away with this Wow ideas king
c5 and then get to d5 I'm 26 seconds
left this one play Bishop f8 very close
as Kings cut off the fascinating
position I think I'm winning takes takes
on b2 I'm pretty sure I'm winning it's
still complicated there we go there we
go okay Maxie that's stressful
so thinking like different ways I
started the kombucha like maybe 20
minutes before the tournament started
hopefully I'll have enough I have
another one in the fridge if I run out
hello to more people the fukes iya
stocked this past pond 99 Nick TV
diamond cutter rocky 35 good to see
everyone playing resolved
let's play a reverse London ooh
ray is winning
Oh mind the structure I for expected it
spawns a bit weak yeah this is very much
like a chess position
not so much king of the hill okay now
I'm gonna get hopefully good night
versus bad bishop my knight will land on
e4 not sure which pawn to take with take
with that pawn wants to play Bishop a3 I
just want to win on the Kings side let's
play this first how do I win I'm Queen
f3
I play rook f3
hmmm I think my King belongs on d7 feels
weird but he wants to do play six moving
way too slowly King d7 yeah King should
be relatively safe
can we need four is a bit scary can play
this move I'm just losing be seven there
way I could take on see one of two try
this move Queen Queen g3 is very
interesting so you gonna play Queen b6
Queen p6 okay I have this move we're
gonna draw they might end up drawing of
Queen c3 and this is not bad very long
time but my Kings closer to the center
again hmm my d5 wait does d4 win d4 on
94b for ticks okay I'm trusting
intuition
okay now I'm just winning GG oh okay
nice next match all right I'm in first
place let's play more king of the hill
staffer gambit again it's gonna be a
long tournament I have to stay calm keep
drinking kombucha I should eat you'll H
5 H 5 yeah I'll play this line oh this
is a funny line
oh my Kings gonna be very close to the
center at the end of this line
Bishop III takes takes Queenie George
III takes takes takes he's gonna have d4
and then I could be annoying okay he's
not going into any of that
hmm Queen e2 is a fine move let's play
this put the bishop on d4 there's now
ideas of lifting the rook if he castles
Queen side I played this before in blitz
hmm could play c5
again my Kings very close to the center
and if we're trading Queens that could
be a very good thing
I have some time advantage this game
which is nice
while castling kingside so I mean Queen
Queen e5 is possible threatening mate
expecting Queen g3 now I'll take and
play this who F takes was very risky he
should have left at 4 open as an option
because now 2 moves away so that was
probably necessary
now maybe f6 oh he has a path - you have
to be very careful here could maybe try
f5 let's try out five so I'm blocking
these squares but for the time being I'm
also blocked oh wow so we wants to play
rook e1 that's take first
I'm so close okay this is very risky but
his night is stuck on c3 which means I
have ideas of B 5 B 4 and this King can
never go to e3 which would allow King be
5 so I'm down I'm down two pawns but
okay pawns don't matter like this is n
game technique king power
I'm b5 is simple plan I mean he might
play a four don't see an idea with that
move creep of this alright now I see so
maybe see Bishop d7 is a move tried
there's a d7
94 maybe just king seasick silent he has
c4 if I take takes rook there mmm this
looks really close to winning oh he's
gonna have c4 though c4 how do I get in
maybe Bishop f5 and his rook is stuck on
this file I know I want to take on d3
that's a fair move so maybe this move
very tense position
we go away with rookie six looks
possible she wants to promote I don't
have much time interesting have to go
for the dirty flag
No
I came down to the wire
I was rough I tried very complex on game
playing Hans Neiman again all right
let's play another one of these openings
that's the same line as Lasky yeah so
this is a line I was referring to
earlier he's gonna play d4 just have to
be careful yeah that's interesting it
was very similar structure oh wow I'm
losing already c5 so he wants to play e5
with Chuck put the bishop on g6 stopping
listen this
I want to play c5 I'm still very very
tricky man if he takes g7 maybe c5 now
it's still tricky because I'm
threatening to take and king e5 if king
of four truck F it's not entirely sure I
mean he might play with chief five but
that I win the night my bishop is so
clutch right now drawing e4
I'm really not sure what he does so this
is a massive threat and this pot is
stuck so he has to play I'm 95 oh wow
95 I can take it though takes oh is this
oh this is gonna get really weird
because then he can take the bishop
takes takes hmm let's try it oh I have
workout 5 and end oh that's so nice
so rook takes Bishop takes King at Fort
Brooke f5 wins
cuz I'll have d5 that's so nice he
probably sees it too yo just add blue
what's up yeah tactics are strange
because like in normal chess it's about
winning material simplifying into when
the endgame this is about getting that
came to the center so it's just another
factor to keep in mind
okay I still have to be careful c3 is
interesting
maybe I just taken c5 and nothing
changed yeah that's nice thing about
having CC pons I'm expecting him to take
the bishop and go into this workout 5
line okay I've got five oking up for
immediately let's play workout 5 huh
still have to be careful
I know I win this I could check oh I
could take first it should be a nice
move then work out five that's a
different move order same ideas apply
rookie seven I should win somehow he's
somehow being resourceful so d4
let's play this move
this is very very tricky there we go
okay two wins and the Rogen's and Hans
or to annul against Hans I should say
can't complain about that
so I'm top something top ten looks like
play d4 y'all stick with London
this guy is slightly low rated yeah for
the most part I'm just sticking with
like standard openings toilet noggin in
the chat what's up toilets this is gonna
be less interaction with the chat and
more like serious even though this is
not real chess this is king of the hill
taking it seriously
it's prize money on the line and pride
and glory more importantly page three
stopping ideas and at age five I want to
do this and attack the pawn eventually
I mean this looks playable my bishop
controls b8 it's very important
yes he has work a seven here he 500 Wow
so e5 we trade everything that he walks
up his King but I have like f4
[Music]
you'll start with spontex because my
King has asked where to eventually I
became lost to e6000 I that night to d4
check also now I have ideas of night
takes b7 Knight d6 also ideas of g4 not
sure how much it accomplishes King e7
well start with III be flexible
yeah it's not gonna be easy to like get
and keep a streak I think my streak is
one game right now so I want to hold on
to my D pawn before playing 94 I also
wanted to just walk and I came to d4 and
win cuz it's hard for him to actually
control the d4 square Wow
yeah that's a playable move maybe not a
94 hit the bishop
ideas of f4 yeah no no I block out the
king - it's very prophylactic I could
take the pawn I like a 4 though I fourth
is g3 and I could take on c6 that
actually looks very pleasant let's take
on c6 so I defend the e pawn I'm
stacking a piece but the play should
flow very nicely
it was kini to king d3 is coming oh I
forgot about that move let's go back
now maybe f4 I'm still very tricky for
takes ticks ticks ticks let's try this
have to keep up some pace I want to get
rid of that knight on e4 we're expecting
in the city to take on e5 with something
not sure what he'll take with maybe
Bishop now takes that's very dangerous
okay I have an idea to check first and
then take and then check and then f4
doesn't seem right though I'm going for
it it's the only thing I see it's really
not what I want to do at least okay I'm
blocking the King from coming to e5 he
was thinking here okay King off 65 or
off for attacking me five not
threatening to take the Knights but now
time to bring my king I'll maybe I can
take this
that's not so comfortable
hmm Eric's coming to the center oh that
was a very good move oh this is not good
I have check this is insane now let's
take that check and blocking mouse
oh no okay
still fine
yes okay 2.8 seconds left there I was
slightly scary but I managed a few of
these schemes are coming down to the
wire
playing Alexander Lenderman man he
finished second last arena Kings right
behind me let's play solidly hey it's
bits from Kingston thanks Kingston Queen
c2
play play c5 some theory of some sort
oh it's more bits from well it subs too
thanks to the new subs I'll look in the
moment from toilet noggin things toilet
noggin this is a scary position I'm
getting distracted slightly but let's
focus
take stick sticks I could take on e4
this looks very scary
what kind take their take sticks didn't
quite work ticks
ready not on the castle okay let's take
your first
okay I'm gonna flaking d7 if he's
beating me in chess I'll try and beat
him in king of the hill to centralize
the King I don't care about pawns I care
about King position he's gonna play
Bishop d2 though and annoy me
maybe I just play a five stock exchange
he's winning all my pawns okay time to
[Music]
attack
I need to train Queens I trade Queens
and I have some hope it's gonna play d5
odd d5 is gonna be painful takes takes
still kind of alive emphasis on kind of
20 for the king there there
maybe this move it's a fancy move as I'm
threatening some ideas h2
there should be six coming it was very
uncomfortable
27 seconds left how do I defend my
bishop
I not defend the bishop that's
unfortunate
oh my gosh
hmm okay I resign where's the resign
button where's the resign button
couldn't find the resign button
okay good game Linderman yeah he just
crushed me I tried to be creative didn't
quite work oh maybe it's under the
game's tab huh all right let's play more
king of the hill we have another line 9
takes
please take on f7 okay we just have like
a Petrov I guess I don't really know any
Theory here but I'll just develop
normally I'm casting makes some sense
and I just lose a pod just lost upon it
again pawns are not too important
yes Center pawns are kind of important
though this is nice move as the bishop
moves I take the knight now I just want
to win the pawn kind of feeling a bit
better and Bishop f5 probably or that
now I want to go for ideas on f4
hmm I just attack each three Ivan and
then Bishop f5 oh it's very close to
working so maybe King King f8 it's a
risk let's play and smooth now Queen c8
like almost worked in that position if
it weren't for Bishop by five I guess
there'd be this [ __ ] f1 to just win this
please I'll try my best
thanks for the moral support still wanna
play Queen d7
pity Queen here does that make any sense
takes its interesting ones very
interesting to rocks versus a queen
meanwhile I just want to play Queen h4
inmates from 22nd place yeah syrup g4
well let's just improve slow and steady
oh wait no if he takes my bishop I take
his rook maybe taking on e3 and the
night of for maybe rookie six first just
want to double up Wow
let's take that take you wants to play
Bishop c4 let's move back
it's still solid position in Queen g7f
five ideas winning the exchange maybe
let's play that move
still feel okay down material but it's
mine use of Queen h6 f5 doesn't quite
work the bishop on d6
my dears of bringing my king here I'm
thinking of six necks
there's why not they should a one bishop
a one bishop a one what is this I want
to play King a five what B 5 let's play
that play this
another time scramble don't need me I
yes okay two seconds left
that's why you need your king clothes to
the center
I thought Bishop a1 was going to be
amazing kind of backfired that then it
all worked out in the end a very clean
win I was going to go to Target today to
my cleaning supplies but after that one
the whole apartment is now clean all
right
h4 all right we have another whatever
you call this London Barry attack easy
to play in Blitz
yeah the Kings will still be relatively
close to the center but I do want to
attack like g4 ideas maybe f3 first g4
Queen h2 eventual mating ideas on each
seven or eight shades hey just flow with
a sub and gay bow tie and tied Walker
also subbing thanks guys
what's the idea behind king of the hill
you want to get your king to the center
Kings move like Knights right
no it's hard to move up in the world I
have to get a streak okay let's put the
put everything on the kingside I think
the strategy in this game is just to go
for meets and queen so the threat is to
take and then probably taking here black
wants to meet me - maybe this move Queen
b6 is coming the Queen b6 oh can I go
away with she this is a bit annoying 19
1
let's play this move I want to take and
take care
Queeny three coming law was scary for
both of us but I do have a time
advantage whoa does this move take
sticks
oh he's gonna take with check
[Music]
that's really nasty
let's take I'm not liking this I'm gonna
try and weather the storm I can't my
keen to the center
so what subtract and I just take on g6
queen before this and there's scary
stuff can you - no I can't
okay let's try this first what is this
position now 24 I run this way
that's gonna be another time scramble
but I'm not getting needed blocks
running low on time
maybe this move
uh Gigi again I'd I'm confused how many
people think like this is real chess is
such an unexpected gift but I'll take
it's playing Lenderman again I would
like to get revenge
he brutally destroys me the last game
and play this line for yeah we're
playing some mainline theory
I'm 95 at some points trying to remember
the theory here yeah that's my g5 and
it's takes takes g6 Queen e2 takes h4
okay yeah this line this is like a Mont
Hamilton's creation and I think the
light this line will be good for me
because I'll take with the King on d2 I
think usually it's Queen takes to you
too though I don't think yeah maybe this
is better I'm not sure let's do that d4
well as d4 pre moved
please c4
I also play g5 so maybe I for first okay
positions closing down and I have h5
interesting we could trade Queens he's
trying to clear the path for his king so
takes maybe g4 here 85 is a good move
though
oh wait let's take that because King f7
or cage seven King e6 rookie 7 mating
ideas looking out 7 I take on b4 takes 4
cage 7q6 rookie sons mates oh that's not
a free Queen but it's still probably
nice to take takes takes I have a 3
it's difficult position wait a minute it
doesn't quite work
I'm just losing I think I'm just losing
yeah here's a resigned pin okay
in-game lunderman strong what to do I
liked my opening that game I'm playing
him on Hamilton it's playing another
London I just mentioned him I just
played his like theoretical line he's
played in like all these high-level
games is he alive
he's alive like knight c6 e five
probably D 5 on the close position or an
open position so he's sacking a piece ok
I'm up a piece this looks strong knife
f5 preventing Heaney seven takes and we
can draw
let's do it
I don't think I want to draw hot but
okay I'll have various options Wow
that was unexpected 96 and takes okay I
still have to be careful maybe f4
I just want to make him think and maybe
flag I'm hitting the bishop more
importantly controlling a5 so I don't
think is king will be able to get to e5
it's just a matter of getting to d5 like
at some point he's gonna try d4 but if
he trades here and plays d4 then I play
c4 I'm just about full/queen to
hmm yeah it's gonna take a lot of coming
back so I don't have a streak falling
pretty far down in the standings but I'm
trying my best and that's what matters
and maybe I'll be beating a chess pro
you guys like the green screen I know
you can't see it
shout out to chest a beautiful green
screen Derek okay let's stay focused oh
that's a fascinating move takes
it was very fascinating move so let's
play this move try and solidify
everything if he takes and I probably
take here and take here and that would
be nice
meanwhile he's flagging he can't handle
my green screen or my kombucha Bishop g4
that's a good move
ticks ticks ticks ticks
hmm it's tricky maybe a Bishop e2 is
best
I'll take there
while I take here some ticks
oh my gosh a long time No kingi five no
forgot he was fighting kini five no I
still have kombucha oh what'd I miss
there he played
oh he played nine of three I had to take
on e4 and yeah should have been a pretty
straightforward win lot of teams are
coming down to just this
he's like time scrambles chess is rough
king of the hill is rougher
okay I'm being aggressive this game he
wants to play Bishop a6 let's play
Queenie to kill has hopes and dreams of
trading off the bishops SL castle
maybe f3 prevent 94 prepare the King
walk
promised f6 is coming that's a very big
problem
it's my dia have and coin off to f6 g4
go for this so there takes takes I think
I'm gonna be down the exchange oh I'm
down the pawn
oh that's very annoying that's very
unfortunate
okay let's try this
the bishop is supposed to be a bad
bishop not a good Bishop still kind of
alive way down on time
yeah Bishop f4 is very painful like what
do I do here I could resign I could flag
or I could fight
finding at least trying to my king is
close to the center as usual down the
exchange I don't think I'm getting
needed just want to win this pond
nice finish was rough
this is a hard tournament their 85th
place of playing this guy again I think
I'd be them last time
the guy was white last time let's see
four okay let's play chess develop
normally at least more normally than
white
yeah the center is gonna be very close
which means it's gonna take a very long
time until either of us gets Hakeem to
the center also this could be a very
long game so time is very important
King sign with us are thanks Kingston
it's a very strong move maybe I could
play Queen g5 trying to win the e3 pod
it's not h4 ideas
I think this is okay his rook g3 takes
we'll trade I'll have nine of six in the
end
you
okay rook F one's coming
then Queen h5 but that doesn't work
[Music]
this is actually very difficult
this is gonna be very ugly hopefully I'm
not getting mated like instantly a truck
takes g7 could be game over
let me be rep Chiat
this looks really bad the Wow we're got
six so fancy I played this move I just
curl up into a ball and pray for the
best break me yeah this doesn't work
because I'll have 96 and then of course
white wants the sacrifice here it's not
so easy
rook h3 I just take and defend
and the fear it's all play g6 r5 defend
with my queen Wow
does this move yeah this is terrifying
takes takes
I can't take that
maybe this move
g6
I want to play f5 I think I'm okay here
yeah if I took the rook I would have
gone severely punished
she wants to take on g6 so maybe it's
still scary
maybe this move
and there's no center square is
accessible okay that's nice just been
another London system don't play this
line
the h5
hey Joanne latrise in the chats
thanks for the bits Joanna this is not
an easy tournament it's been rough so
far I'm keeping my king in the center
may be expecting King of seven that's
also reasonable
let's maybe play let's bring the knight
to c5
I'm double on the e-file this is pawn as
a bit backwards
Queeny six ideas like rookie a Queenie
six I'll cut the King off Oh Queen not
four
okay Queen off for all play King b19 a
fate while I could take the pawn
I'm liking my position the rooks
attacked my rooks attacked what's going
on here I mean I have to play it safe a
d5 also hanging so rook - you expected
and then they'd see five maybe Queen
Queen c7 with idea Queen e5 and now
Knight c5 I'll come back to the e-file
this pawn is very tender juicy you
seventh on okay that's tricky I can't
take the rook I could play Knight e3 and
rook c6
maybe 93 I want to chase the Queen away
from defending or from attacking my rook
that's a reasonable move maybe G 3
I'll get the d4 square I'll have ideas
of c3 and winning has to take my queen
I'm liking the structure a very easy
plan now
you should've played rook c6 rook see
for now he's going for it
probably this move two moves away
pretty sure this is completely winning
it's moving yeah once like play that
move it's over okay
that was nice next game relatively high
rated player so I need a streak if I
make any running in this tournament I
have 24 Tournament points playing a 1545
okay let's have some fun why are people
playing the C formula so confused
Kingston with hundred more bits
thanks Kingston I'm being aggressive f2
can't adequately be defended
oh my night but he didn't take it that's
nice let's take this way
kingi - Wow put the bishop on d4
yeah the king should not be making any
progress
92 I'll play c5 maybe I have some
painting ideas
some ideas about five this looks good
enough
actually if he takes maybe I play rip t8
yeah this looks very nice wait this is
meat this is force mates okay all right
Kings need some quick wins like that so
nice next match hmm a bow tez is a good
player have to agree we need to play
this move
yeah interesting line can't complain
with this position though I'll have
better development I'll probably castle
and end up going for just normal chests
I appointed not going for normal chests
let's take there
how do I win
then keep Queens on the board that's a
good move to check I like a queenside
castle threatening me in one let's do
that threatening me
haha that's nice okay it's ironic when
you Castle queenside fur to protect your
own King and checkmate the other King
alright play the same opening so I'm in
19th place
yeah I like this opening
maybe Castle queenside make a chart I'd
use a 5/5 and ideas of f4 I could have
played Bishop e7 but I don't want to
trade pieces maybe f4 now
Quincy for Queen d7
okay let's attack the Bishop h4 maybe
yeah yeah I still like the position
Wow g4 I could on Poisson think I'll
just move back I want to take the bishop
have more access to the H file I don't
think this affects my real Blitz rating
it should affect my king of the hill
rating each file is now open not so
simple though let's knock the D pawn
hard for white to defend
so Bishop check and takes and this looks
very very strong this is very close to
winning if not for Queen here real cure
here
wait does this make Queen d2 Queen d2
check this has got to be good are we
gonna see a windmill we might see a
windmill Chuck where's my mate there oh
no it's just gonna be me I do have a
windmill if I want it I guess
rook F 2 here and then takes and then
here and then me on each one or help
like Queen d4 I need better move here
maybe this is better
those nice feels a nice like temporary
queen sac Bishop e6 is very calm check
and ooh didn't see that I mean there's
millions of ways to win this let's do
this I'll just get the King to the
center
okay those nice so I have some kind of
streak I think a five-game streak of 36
tournament points 20 behind the leader
Jack Rogers playing some Spanish name
I'll spend tosh.o we have a Dutch
defense okay I'll still play a London h4
idea that the son of is to play some
early c5
so he's rated 1228 okay let's be
aggressive I was taking it seriously me
some opening as I should but sometimes I
do change my like playing style based on
the opponents
yeah I mean earlier in the tournament I
was playing a lot of like very high
rated players now it seemed to calm down
a little bit
hey food is flying with a sub let's do
this
oh it's al Aspen Tahoe Aspen Tahoe yeah
I don't know why pastor J I took like
four years of Spanish in high school all
right next game oops
what just happened next match all right
Oh playing this guy again I beat him
last time we played of this opening
again and night before is like some
novelty by Larry Kaufman what do I do
here efore probably and then takes takes
an f5 ideas
wait I can't play Queenie seven cuz you
castles so there should be compensation
like somewhere in this line okay so
cakes problem is I don't want the King
to get too close to the center but maybe
it's okay
yeah I won't Castle queenside I want my
my King to stay close to the center not
the pawn I want to bring the King just a
six
he can't access either of these squares
be nice if I can get a quick win95
coming
maybe f6 idea of g4 or g5 g for the
excellency 7 I might sack the exchange
maybe g5 here
ambition t4
we just want to put the bishop on e5
oh wow
I forgot about that move I think it's
okay little bit sketchy
I'm so close
both of these squares while g4 so let's
just take a pond because it would have
been annoying if you took there
now some idea of taking on d1 and then
rook h3 in the end to remove the Knights
but feeling this is winning I want to
take rook h3 remove the light and then
just wind now he's going to check from
behind sneaky
that's not so easy so there there may be
c5 there's night this move
let's try this
Oh No kindiy three okay didn't see it
oh so sad so so sorry what to do okay
new game half hour left
hopefully this is started a streak of
some sort
yeah my opponents low-rated I'm well
aware so I'm keeping my king in the
center hoping for some some sort of
quick win I might have to go for some
attack though I'm so far he's playing
well or at least decently
okay making the game sharp giving away a
g7 pawn some ideas of taking if Queen
takes I might end up meeting Queen g5 at
least when the e5 pond
yeah I'm being hyper aggressive here I'm
attacking the bishop
[Music]
I want to somehow someday again in 92
it's not so easy to prepare
let's take that Bishop i5 I take it and
defend my queen okay
you're head of feeling he might fall
into that all right now I'm just up in
night I'll keep the King cut off
probably g5 that's quickest way
yeah now this will come why did he not
take the night earlier if this were in
an arena format I would go back and look
but to move on its next game
I'm sure there's there's many
inaccuracies in these games though
playing stoic okay let's play maybe I
should've played 4 let's play some
aggressive line I should have five I
have three
is there an engine to analyze king of
the hill pretty sure there is on me
chess I don't know about chess calm I
would imagine maybe it's not the
clearest answer I can check afterwards
now do all go insane and play kini to
King III or h4 h5 maybe h4 h5 just go
for the attack
time to rock lift oh this is very nice
now
as the bishop will have to move and I'll
take on each six and then g7 will be
weak the bishop moves back maybe not h4
Wow okay let's take here first and then
now I'm just going for mates
I haven't had like too many checkmates
on the board so how do I actually win
this position oh this will be funny
he'll take on c3 then I play Bishop T to
check hitting the king
mmm yeah let's just go for King
centralization or a rope cheating one
okay all right I'm I'm close to breaking
the top ten playing the chess coach play
another London yeah early B sixes
sometimes asking to get punished it's
like in this slide I'm not winning the
exchange I guess we're just trading
I'll try Queen a4 and bring the Knight
to e5 yeah this is a strong threat my
play like rook c8 or f6 the rook on d1
hmm okay some open h-file can't complain
with that
so it takes let's take first and open
the D file
I'm preventing castling because Queen
takes I have a news of maybe four
some funny line of taking g6 and winning
back the Queen not going into it and now
I'm threatening my g6 which I don't know
how lock stops it's still not g6
it's a nice little tactic okay so I'm up
the exchange but it's still a little bit
tricky I have to make sure he 5 and d5
are covered might be able to attack from
behind
sort with g4
yeah we see this a lot where the the
pawns are in the way and like if he
pushes and I push so there's no like
easy wind I don't think I was like B 5 B
3 he might go for like a 5 if he ever
plays out 5 I have rookie a check
I'm Bishop e7
meantime I want to run in so I think f5
was expected at some point
okay this is very nice now I went five
with the rook this should be completely
winning Oh in d4 okay 14th place I can
play in g5 maybe I could have like g5 at
some points yeah but London structure I
mean it's a closed centre so it's not
doesn't really lead to like a quick win
with getting the King to the center but
it's it's more of a chess position more
principles of chess apply okay playing
some GM Paul from SP be playing the
slide play Bishop f4 I think this is
playable we can trade a bit ke7
interesting very interesting
play night c4f three
oh he's gonna play b5
fascinating efore ticks hmm I kind of
like he for I'm sacking a piece I mean
maybe I already blundered the piece but
trying to get the most for my piece I'm
threatening this I'm fighting this I'm
controlling these squares d-file there's
still tension it's hard for a box to the
fence c4 and okay the king is is
somewhat precarious Lee placed what's
the box pieces still not developed
so I feel like top-10 finish would be a
good result and hopefully easy like
easily jump to eighth hey it's bits from
supersymmetry 200 gets let's get top 10
that's what I'm gonna try and do I have
to keep up some pace yeah my king will
be active wait am i meeting check what's
so close to me I'm not quite lucky
enough to he's gonna play c5 just
activate the rook dreaming of this and
then somehow meaning
very very close it's so close oh I need
to remove this pawn he doesn't have a be
fun to play b6 she does have a bishop
so take sticks this looks good
I just want to get in mmm
this is a nice line Bishop e6 check no
he took my rook oh no I forgot he could
take my rook oh my gosh are you serious
oh no that's calculating this all right
how do you think this this and then King
g4 oh that's so unfortunate there goes
my attempt for a greatness it's such a
great position to
heipo genetic toast thanks for subbing
need to relieve the pain somehow ok I'm
playing another 1100 I mean should I
like control the center then walk in
some funny trap takes there should be 5
c6 king d3 you can't stop king takes d4
that's what I'm hoping for now it's a
bit different I'm going insane here I'm
like very very tilted from asking hoping
for some nice outcome
yeah I don't care anymore about material
or principles I just care about getting
the King to d4
oh well how about Queen 64 it's actually
not a bad position though we might trade
Queens
oh did someone clip that it's not my
proudest moments this is a proud moment
though no stopping king d4 okay still
trying to get top ten I'm so close yet
not so close we'll have a little bit of
intermission here by the opponents time
ticks down okay
there's less than ten minutes whoa
anonymous gift or gifting subs thanks
from on the skiff er where these no sobs
aids three five nine as he is straw go
cool nine nine nine
who's now who knows at and xxx ten two
chests
welcome to the sub Club everyone alright
let's play aggressively let's play I
think this time I'll just go for a quick
meet like Bishop c5
be very aggressive target the III pawn I
had this line a few times already
he's playing it decently okay let's play
can I come from behind let's come from
behind I came from behind and now I'm
having forks all over the place
this pawn is gonna fall the rook might
fall if d4c five
I mean let's just take a pawn we have to
be very careful Chuck maybe y'all just
get my King to the center
I still have to be careful
okay I think this is working d5 c5 takes
here and then I'll get to t5 I don't
think there's any prizes for getting top
ten but mean I'm within range
so I'm threatening to take and play b5
in King g5
while house Neiman's winning the
tournament - I beat him like twice early
on life isn't fair sometimes yeah this
is winning okay now it's all about time
okay next match so I'm in 12th place so
I'm kind of close kind of sort of
waiting for next game okay let's just be
aggressive grand free attack time
yeah I'm just gonna throw stuff at the
King and hope it works sacking and
Knights a slightly questionable opening
oh well good news
oh man we're gonna be losing a lot of
stuff unless he drops his queen like
that yeah there could have been like a
very bad for me
yeah I'm gonna try and go for meats ASAP
as possible so now I just need to gather
Queen to h6 and that'll be mates
there we go next game
thanks Matt hey I'm number eight I'm
playing Hans Neiman okay this could be
the last game reverse Cambridge Springs
move a six let's play this move Oh what
to do take maybe other smooth looks
interesting
want to put the rook here
let's take that take that
it's slightly unpleasant and it's 3r
acute there
okay down upon the reasonable position
what's the standings oh I am Jack Rogers
it's close to catching him but I'm still
taught eight he wants to draw not yet I
want to try and play for a win on the
play rookie seven
hmm takes getting this and this
I take that maybe not
okay draw how do I offer a draw-game
draw okay we drew next match yeah I
think this happens like when you're at
the end of the tournament just try and
get like final points by drawing people
okay I'm playing a budapest this'll be a
fun line
this is a very fun line 41 seconds left
in the tournament it's clear this
yeah it's bits offer draw hey top ten
supersymmetry thanks four bits yeah the
unfortunate thing is like when the
tournament ends again just aborts so we
don't get to finish this this
masterpiece White's completely winning
like Bishop d3 would you broth anyway
that was fun
can't complain with the finish now let
me ask does a top 10 finish give me like
enough points for the overall like
scoring system oh maybe not oh it's just
top eight oh that's unfortunate I have
the window here of like the arena King
points I can move over I'm not blocking
it if we zoom in here so this is season
four so I actually I got a hundred
points last time for winning it and I
guess this time I just got five points
for a tenth place finish and I need 125
points so I'll have many more
opportunities I mean I just have to
stream I guess like for more events okay
well congratulations Hans Ninan winning
the whole thing
you